tacuba llevaba apenas un año operando en
mali pero para este grupo de fuerzas
especiales europeas es hora de hacer las
maletas desde el golpe de mayo de 2021
las relaciones entre parís y bamako se
han deteriorado requiriendo una
reorganización del aparato militar en el
sahel tras el anuncio de la retirada de
las fuerzas de la operación marcan en
febrero los militares de tacuba deben
salir del país en el momento de su
creación en 2020 esta fuerza reunía a
800 soldados de 10 países europeos
francia bélgica república checa
dinamarca estonia hungría italia países
bajos portugal y suecia el proyecto
dirigido por florian es par la entonces
ministra de las fuerzas armadas
pretendía compartir con otros países
europeos la pesada tarea de combatir a
los yihadistas en el sahel especialmente
en la zona denominada tres fronteras
entre níger malí y burkina faso otra
misión era ayudar a las fuerzas
valientes a ganar la autonomía y para
que puedan desarrollar unidades
dedicadas a luchar contra grupos
vinculados a al qaeda o al
autodenominado estado islámico
el prematuro final de tacuba parís se
jacta de haber conseguido reunir a los
estados miembros de la unión europea en
una lucha conjunta contra los grupos
terroristas armados en el sahel